everyone falls down
getting back up is how you learn how to
walk
i think it's important to have a good
heart failure when you're young
i learned a lot out of that because it
makes you kind of aware of what can
happen to you
it's kind of fun to do the impossible
is timeless
imagination has no age
dreams are forever
[Music]
if you can dream it
you can do it
the way to get started is to quit
talking
and begin doing
the more you like yourself
the less you are like anyone else which
makes you unique
our greatest natural resource is the
minds of our children
first think
second
believe
third
dream
and finally dare
everyone needs deadlines
even the beavers they loaf around all
summer but when they are faced with the
winter deadline
they work like fury
if we didn't have deadlines we'd
stagnate
never get bored or cynical
yesterday is a thing of the past
all the adversity i've had in my life
all my troubles and obstacles have
strengthened me
you may not realize it when it happens
but a kick in the teeth may be the best
thing in the world for you
that's the real problem with the world
too many people grow up
they forget
those who have money are not always
happy
i know guys who were practically
starving
but they got much more pleasure from
life than millionaires
because they did what they wanted
[Music]
it's a mistake not to give people a
chance to learn to depend on themselves
while they are young
people often ask me if i know the secret
of success
and if i could tell others how to make
their dreams come true
my answer is
you do it by working
the greatest moments in life are not
concerned with selfish achievements
but rather with the things we do for the
people we love and esteem
and whose respect we need
why do we have to grow up
i know more adults who have the
children's approach to life
they are not afraid to be delighted with
simple pleasures and they have a degree
of contentment with what life has
brought
sometimes it isn't much either
our next video will definitely surprise
you
click on it